we may be on the brink of getting
ourselves an active investigation into a
sitting Supreme Court justice let's
think back to Brett Cavanaugh skon
formation hearings for a moment anyone
with even the most basic critical
thinking and english language skills
should have come away from Brett
Cavanaugh's confirmation hearings
thinking that he wasn't being completely
truthful about some of the things that
he said and of course he ultimately did
become Supreme Court justice for life
that isn't ultimately going to stop an
investigation into possible perjury by
Cavanaugh though because we have video
of democratic congressman Jonah goose
from Colorado who's on the House
Judiciary Committee he told constituents
on Friday that they are likely going to
open an investigation into Brett
Kavanaugh for perjury take a look at the
video from the event against so I think
that's another thing that will come up
before
I think the tertiary committee is likely
to take that up now immediately some
other Democrats were saying
Jonah goose is a freshman he has no idea
what's going on and it's going to be
very very difficult to actually run an
investigation an active investigation
into a sitting Supreme Court justice but
we will see a relevant question would be
which of Bret Cavanaugh statements does
he believe our perjury was it about his
statements to investigators who were
looking into sexual assault claims
against them was it statements he made
senators was it his claims about when he
learned certain facts related to the
accusations against him and if you're
hearing me list that you're probably
thinking the same thing as me which is
that perjury is very difficult to prove
under any circumstances and particularly
when it's perjury related to when
someone learned something these are very
very difficult things to prove perjury
on and that's why perjury convictions
are relatively rare but the one sort of
supporting element to this is that
congressman Jerry Nadler was overheard a
couple of months ago or last month I
guess maybe two months ago on an Amtrak
train saying that it would be possible
to impeach Brett Kavanaugh as a judge I
I don't know that I see this as
particularly likely Pat but if there's
reason to think he perjured himself I
support an investigation and let the
findings fall where they may
it's gonna be so tough to prove I think
because when he said that he never
blacked out from drinking only he is the
only he himself as the person who knows
for sure that he did or didn't ever
black out when he talks about poofing
like only him and his small circle of
friends can like know if that meant anal
sex or if I meant farting or whatever
the hell that thing meant it's gonna be
very hard to pinpoint down some of this
stuff because you're dealing with slang
and colloquialisms
I don't think you're gonna be able to
prove it I don't disagree with you but
let's investigate
let's subpoena you know boofer Maggie
and Joe Devil's Triangle Smith and
whoever else might have something to say
about all this stuff and in particular
let's get that guy mark judged who
evaded having to actually speak publicly
during the confirmation hearings let's
see what they all have to say under oath
and in the end I think that you are
right that perjury is always hard to
prove beyond a doubt it will be
particularly difficult here but I look
forward to seeing Cavanaugh's reaction
to the investigation if one ultimately
does get going one of today's sponsors
is privacy comm slash Pakman this is a
free service that I've actually been
using myself for a while now and I love
it you just take a few seconds to link
your debit card or bank account to
privacy coms mobile app or browser
extension for Firefox and Chrome and
what that does is allow you to instantly
create virtual credit cards that are
linked to your bank account so that
you're not actually putting your real
debit card number on the internet and
you use these virtual credit card
numbers to buy things online and with
one click of a button you have the
ability to create multiple virtual cards
delete cards freeze and unfreeze cards
you can put a limit on a card so a
company won't be able to charge you more
than you actually want them to and it
protects you from being hacked it
protects you from companies being hacked
which we've been talking about for a
while on the program and it's perfect
for signing up for free trial somewhere
if you don't want your real credit card
number to be exposed and on file and
their app and browser extension let you
autofill the virtual credit card number
into the credit card field when you're
buying things online there are a ton of
different advantages to shopping and
paying bills with a system like this
everything is totally secure and
encrypted and in some situations you can
earn 5% cash back on your purchases it's
all completely free all you have to do
is click the link under this video to
get started and for a limited time
everybody in our
audience who signs up gets $5.00 towards
your first purchase when you sign up
using that link below